I am pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Alice K Wolfe mayor of the
city of Cambridge in the Honorable her
Helio Barco president of the Republic of
Colombia president Barco will now give
the address
[Applause]
prescient gray members of the board
distinguished guests class of 1990 in a
few short days each of you will be
entering a new stage in life new careers
new opportunities new challenges in a
few short months I will be leaving the
office of president of Columbia I have
been on a long and fascinating journey
since that day in 1943 when when like
all of you today I received my degree
from MIT I remember that day well so
many things raised through my mind so
much was happening in the world so much
was happening so fast social political
and economic orders were turn upside
down by events around the world
overnight
it seemed borders were changing in
Europe no one was sure what tomorrow
will bring
all of this must sound strangely
familiar to each of you with the rapid
rate of change in Europe and around the
world
all of it may be a bit overwhelming as
well I can understand the feeling in my
senior year in my room at the graduate
house I remember feeling a bit
overwhelmed myself for what the future
might bring little did I know that a few
years later I will be deeply involved in
politics elected to the House of
Representatives only to have Congress
shut down as violence against my party
broke out a year later I returned to
Boston
with my new
to obtain a graduate degree at MIT
soon after my first child Karolina was
born here at the Massachusetts General
Hospital at the same time my friend and
Joan professor Paul Samuelson and his
wife had triplets I knew I had to return
to Colombia at a time of crisis but
little did I know what extraordinary
events will shape my life in public
service I have learned that our lives
and careers are shaped by outside forces
often beyond our control throughout our
lives we are faced with important
choices in the end I realize how
important it is to establish a set of
values and beliefs to guide these
choices I also realized that a strong
foundation in the humanities economics
and technology was the key for each
teach through these basic disciplines
that we manage change there are truly at
the core of social progress now this
enormously powerful tools of change
rests in your hands and the fate of
future generations depends on your
ability to put to good use all that you
have learned your families your
professors and I are all confident that
each of you can meet the challenge this
pace of change and the rigors of
academic life have a times I am sure
left you gasping for breath wondering if
the world of learning around you will
ever slow down today you can stop and
take a breath look back on the years you
have spent at MIT look beyond the long
hours and hard
work but you have achieved today he said
true compliment to all of you and you
should stop and savor the moment commit
to memory the time you have spent here
and what you have done in the future you
will look back on these years as a time
of great excitement of great challenges
and of great ideas
it was a time when many of life's
mundane details could be set aside so
you could focus on ideas or learning on
experiencing the thrill of academic life
you will look back at these years at a
time when life was lived to its fullest
when bonds of friendship were built
bonds that will last your entire lives
never forget that
what you have learned here it will serve
you well for years to come
indeed it has served me very well in
many ways this is sounds also a proud
day in my life today I also find myself
poised at the edge of a new time in my
life
this is speech to the class of 1990 at
my alma mater will be one of the last
major speeches of my presidency soon I
will depart elected office and seek new
challenges in my life some have asked
how I managed to the job of president as
such difficult times I tell them that it
is nothing compared to taking the oral
PhD examination at MIT
in many ways my situation is much like
yours together we enter a new time in
our lives at time with new opportunities
and new responsibilities we must enter
this new time bravely holding the early
to the values that we have been taught
to cherish at home at school and here at
MIT no doubt all of you expect me to
talk about an issue that has stirred the
hearts and minds and emotions of
millions around the world it is the use
it is an issue I have come to represent
one which has even led to some
controversy in this campus I am sure you
expected me to use this time with you to
discuss the scourge of illegal narcotics
but what but that is not what I have
come here to speak about today
I hope my views on this issue are well
known by now every day you read about
our struggle against narco terrorism and
drug trafficking in Colombia this
struggle will continue when I leave
office for good men and women everywhere
will not tolerate misery and violence
bred by those who push and those who
consume illegal drugs
no today I want to explore with you a
wider vision and the events that will
shape a new global order in the 21st
century for all days a day which has
such personally important to me and to
each of you
this is delay the day to look forward
not to look back like more of you here
in Colombia we watched on television the
wall come down in Berlin with rapt
attention from people power in the
Philippines to black Clare havens Velvet
Revolution to the no vote in Chile
democracy is on the rise around the
globe as totalitarian governments are
tossed off by people Restless to
experience a war of freedom for all this
devoted to the cause of freedom we share
in the celebration of democracy
democracy is not a distant notion at all
in Colombia indeed our position in Latin
America is somewhat unique our
Constitution is nearly as all the sewers
and our democratic institution have have
long been a model to our neighbors this
is the true significance of your current
struggle for the greatest threat to our
democracy is narco-terrorism and in
insatiable worldwide demand for drug
which fuels it in the past you you we
usually saw extremist ideologies as the
most serious threat to democracy but now
drugs and organized crime are even more
dangerous not only to our democracy but
to us as well this is an auspicious
moment to reflect on our changing world
and a new global order look at what has
happened since I graduated from MIT in
1943 a terrible war was raging in Europe
and Asia
taking lives and devastating the
countryside at every turn no one can
ever forget it tragedy of this war the
45 million killed the NASA death camps
the destruction of towns cities of lives
and hopes of generations to come the use
of atomic weapons at Hiroshima and
Nagasaki seven years later when I
returned to to MIT for postgraduate
studies
Europe was still rebuilding the ravages
of this war of the Cold War appeared to
be a reality that will never leave
Soviets and Americans stood poised
ready to strike each other at a moment's
notice
threatening the existence of the human
right race around the world democracy
was in retreat and totalitarian regime
flourished on nearly every continent the
result of the talat Aryan regimes in
Latin America were the same as
everywhere the crushing of the will of
the people the violation of fundamental
human right the demise of democracy
during this cold war the developed world
chose to look the other way as millions
in Latin America suffer under oppression
u.s. foreign policy remain fixated on
east-west competition and north-south
view rarely came into focus and yet in
the last decade Democratic Change has
swept our continent ten years ago most
countries of Latin America suffer under
the weight of dictatorships just look at
the change Peru returned to democracy in
1984 Libya in 1982 and Tina in 1983
Brazil in 1985
Chile Nicaragua Panama in the last year
alone almost a whole continent has moved
from military rule to lay it legitimate
legitimately elected leaders still
evidence of North America's virus to the
Cold War ideology this dramatic change
so close to your borders received
relatively little attention now it's
time to open our eyes to a new world
after years of superpower conflict each
one of you what each one is vying for
good gains in the high-stakes game for
global military advantage we are now
able to see beyond the east-west
confrontation today's global order no
longer rests on the foundation of
security concerns military might is no
longer with the terminus as countries
place in the international system we are
now able to look beyond the myopia of
the Cold War
vision Oh previously clouded horizon to
where a new world is waiting
a world where economic growth and
technological innovation will be of
critical importance not sheer military
strength a were were were entrepreneurs
and innovators will lead the way not the
generals of yesterday witness Japan a
country that spends little on military
but that has suddenly leaped to the
front ranks of were powers it is a
country that gives more economic aid to
the third world than any other nation
including historical in generous United
States dismal military establishment of
Japan presents no serious threat to the
vast armies of the US or Soviet Union
but through its economic might it will
through global influence today which
country I ask do others most want to
emulate today Japan or the Soviet Union
the economic growth through Asia and in
Europe has been extraordinary now we
must work to spend the economic success
of these dynamic regions to other areas
this is particularly true for the
fragile new democracies of
for these countries to solidify their
political gains they will need economic
success from Poland to Argentina to the
Philippines nearly free people expect
economic growth and improved living
standards and in order to maintain
stability this expectation must be met
it is your responsibility and those in
other wealthy countries to ensure the
fostering of global economic growth in
this way you can help these fledgling
democracies as they struggle to spread
their wings this is especially true in
Latin America a region which
historically historically has received
far too little attention the best way to
foster north-south cooperation will not
be through military means but rather by
guaranteeing access of Latin America's
democracies to economic prosperity and
change just as history will recall the
1980s as an era when democratic forces
swept the globe
it will also be remember I said the cade
of resurgence in free-market economics
this is a revolution of enormous
significance a recognition of our global
economy and a confirmation that open
economies with access to markets can
lead to social progress it seems that in
long-running match between Karl Marx and
an Adam Smith is finally coming to an
end
I applaud this development but at the
risk of sounding passe let me issue a
warning in our rise to embrace free
market forces let us not lose sight of
the fundamental role of government and
it embodies the free and collective will
of its people there is a role for both
market forces and we stayed in solving
social problems free-market policies
should not be used as an excuse for the
lack of political will where it is a
sure injustice of fighting our drug
trafficking or providing basic education
and health care free market economics is
not a magic wand which somehow will
relieve us of the obligation to care for
our fellow human beings
no where is the role of the state as
clear as with another global issue which
has been pushed aside for too long the
preservation of our environment this is
a struggle that must be won or highest
priorities in the decade of the 90s I
firmly believe that the industrialized
countries have an ecological debt to
humanity unless in less than two
centuries Industrial Development has not
only destroyed most of the native
forests of Europe and North America but
also has brought pollution acid rain and
destruction to the ozone layer this is
an ecological debt to future generations
who will have to live with the
consequences of our thoughtless ways in
which the developed countries have
achieved the standard of living the
burden of sustaining a viable planetary
environment now rests clearly on the
shoulders of the third world for we are
the last frontier of unspoiled lands the
only way our countries can meet this
challenge is by defeating rural poverty
and economic stagnation the best way for
the United States and other
industrialized countries to pay their
ecological debt to humanity is to be the
partners in this cause my administration
has already set aside more than 14
million acres of rainforest as Indian
reserves in the Amazon region an area
larger larger than these six New England
states together
let us pledge to seek some development
policies which recognize the value of
our most precious resources let us place
to retire this debt now for future
generations
you are you are indeed as fortunate as I
was to be embarking on new careers
during a watershed period the record of
human history is marked by these moments
of fundamental change you now inherit a
new global order with new challenges and
extraordinary opportunities as you
watched the joy of your joint German
colleagues dancing in the streets or the
soul of the faces of daughter brave
young students at kahneman square or the
courage of young Colombian soldiers
fighting for democracy against narco
terrorists it may have been difficult
for you here on this beautiful campus in
Boston to truly appreciate such
democratic furrball here in America
where so much is so often taken for
granted this struggle for democracy may
indeed seem distant however you are all
new graduates one of the world's most
prestigious academic institutions that
honor brings with it a special
responsibility the new democracies
around the world are fragile and need
your help to survive as you look to your
future I ask one thing to the LED
today's flowering democracies wither on
the vine
extend your arms to those who have for
too long lived in oppression in fear and
in poverty like all the newborns
these infant democracies around the
world may at times falter and stumble
hesitantly trying their first steps yet
they must prevail this is our first duty
all of us especially you here in the
United States now have an opportunity to
build in peace what what is often
unavailable by force it is our
collective responsibility to ensure that
this opportunity does not pass us by you
have been well trained I have no doubt
that you have the intellectual power to
face any challenge I harbor the hopes
that you will also have the heart to
meet these challenges with fairness and
compassion I know you will for this
after all is our shared heritage and you
my friends are now the guardians of our
shared vision thank you
you